la ministra de salud chilena Jimena
Aguilera anunció este miércoles la
extensión de la alerta sanitaria que
rige en Chile hasta marzo de 2023 esto
ante la incertidumbre que genera la
situación epidemiológica sobre la covid
que se vive en este momento en China y a
la que ha hecho referencia la
Organización Mundial de la Salud al
Mostrar su preocupación por el
incremento significativo de cuadros
graves Esto hace que se mantenga esta
situación de alerta por ver qué es lo
que pudiera pasar Aunque a la ciudadanía
en este momento la covid no es una de
las cuestiones que más le preocupe están
agobiados por temas como la inflación o
los problemas de seguridad que se viven
en el país en la última jornada se
registraban un total de 5.000 casos
positivos y una positividad bastante
alta un 18,75% a nivel nacional que era
superado en 19% en el caso de la región
metropolitana el incremento de casos ha
ascendido un 15% en las últimas dos
semanas y un 12% en la última semana
mientras que las regiones del país que
tienen una tasa de incidencia por cien
mil habitantes más altas están todas al
norte arica y parignacota atacama
antofagasta y calama esto en un contexto
total en el que más de 5 millones de
chilenos de los 19 que existen en el
país se han contagiado y en el que el
número de fallecidos supera a las 63.000
personas un momento en el que en chile
no se ven mascarillas en la calle ya no
es obligatorio y sólo continúa siendo
obligatorio llevar mascarilla en
recintos médicos y hospitalarios